bonjour je suis vraiment contente d'être
ici
vous savez une des premières révélations
que j'ai eu dans ma carrière en
management je l'ai eu ici à HEC Montréal
dans un cours de management culturel
j'étais dans mon cours et le professeur
Wendy oui nous a présenté un texte le
texte makozy sur le lit de chip il
s'appelle narcissique
de
invitée
narcissique comment ils impactent le
monde comment ils font peut-être du tort
aux organisations mais bizarrement c'est
pas ce que j'ai retenu ce jour-là
cet article parlait du bras droit de ses
leaders
et tout d'un coup quand j'ai lu
l'article je me suis dit ah mais moi je
suis le site j'ai trouvé que mon rôle
était très important dans cette
organisation
mais après je me suis rendu compte que
je n'avais pas peut-être bien lu ou que
l'article ne mettait pas en perspective
les effets néfastes de ce type de
leadership sur les autres personnes et
sur leur organisation
quelques années après avoir lu l'article
ce qui devait arriver
arriva par un jour monotone d'hiver il
faisait froid il faisait gris vous savez
ce jour de janvier on dit que c'est le
jour le plus déprimant de l'année
je me suis dit que c'était intenable que
j'en pouvais plus la tension entre
mon désir d'épanouissement et il
engagement profond que j'avais pour
cette organisation était à son comble
c'était vraiment difficile mais j'ai
décidé qu'il fallait que je démissionne
et j'ai démissionné
en même temps que le deuil a été
vraiment difficile et il est encore
parfois aujourd'hui
j'ai eu une sensation dans mon corps
vraiment importante enfin je sentais que
je menais
enfin je sentais que je me donnais de la
place
et à partir de ce jour je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que je me norme en fait de
façon consciente mais comment le faire
par la poste pandémie alors où on parle
de démission
silencieuses on parle de
désacralisation du travail il me paraît
de plus en plus important de se nourrir
dans la vie et au travail et pourquoi
parce que il faut s'encrer avoir un
sentiment
d'appartenance
sentir que notre attention elle est
claire
développée une confiance envers
nous-mêmes mais aussi entre nous pour
briser le sentiment
d'isolement quand on travaille dans une
petite organisation artistique on se
sent souvent isolés
et parce que je crois que nous avons
besoin d'être vivant et authentique
Oscar Wilde dit soyez vous-même parce
que les autres sont déjà pris
vous me direz oui et c'est bien comment
être authentique comment être soi-même
vous savez cette année pendant ce
cheminement j'ai été accompagné par deux
coachs formidables franchement je les
adore
i love Jani et le docteur yacha que je
croyais travail sur la neurosciences et
sur le fonctionnement du cerveau pour
accompagner les personnes dans leur
changement dans leur cheminement
la première question que mes couches
m'ont posées et qu'il pose à toutes les
personnes c'est quels sont vos trois
valeurs essentielles
et après je me suis rendu compte que
c'était ça en fait mes propres valeurs
ne correspondaient pas au fonctionnement
de l'organisation
et j'ai envie de vous donner ce conseil
aujourd'hui aussi
quels sont les valeurs qui font que
quand vous marchez quand vous vous tenez
devant les gens vous pensez que vous
êtes la meilleure version de vous-même
vous sentez que vous êtes bien à votre
place
vous le sentez dans votre corps
je pense que ces valeurs
nous permettent de mieux prendre nos
décisions de orienter nos comportements
de Danner une manière à la façon dont
nous serons en relation avec nous-mêmes
mais aussi avec les autres c'est comme
une entente qu'on prend un verre nous
même moral pour vivre avec intégrité
je n'ai pas dit tout à l'heure mais je
suis restée 20 ans dans cette
organisation culturelle
j'étais comme dans un état de d'hyper
vigilance et de douce révoltes
en fait chaque jour frénétiquement
j'essaie de me contrôler ce que je
devais dire ou ne pas dire ce que je
devais faire ou ne pas faire à qui je
devais parler ou ne pas parler j'étais
danseuse comment bien tenir mon corps
toujours je contralais tout mais en fait
j'étais comme une adolescente parce que
ça commençait à craquer cette histoire
là
j'ai commencé à me révolter mais en même
temps je gardais ce maintien de contrôle
ce que j'ai fait c'est que au fil du
temps je commençais à tester ma capacité
d'être à l'extérieur de la maison parce
que en fait dans cette hyper vigilance
que ce que je ressentais c'est que ma ma
manière d'être mon authenticité d'être
et de penser était constamment critiqué
constamment réévaluer donc j'ai dû aller
à l'extérieur pour tester ça comme une
vraie adolescente donc j'ai étudié j'ai
été dans plusieurs organisations
associations je me suis impliquée chaque
jour et je sais que pour certains ça
c'est naturel c'est élargir son réseau
mais pour moi c'était de la survie
il fallait que je me retrouve quelque
part et que je j'ose être moi-même
ailleurs et maintenant je me dis que
ce n'est plus de la survie et en fait je
suis très fière que
ces événements de survie c'était un
intestin pardon un intestin un instant
féroce de survivance qui m'a permis
d'aller plus loin et je vous conseille
cela en fait d'essayer d'autres
expériences de vous mettre sainement au
défi
je suis restée 20 ans je le dis encore
dans cette organisation j'aurais pu
m'auto flageller d'avoir supporté ses
souffrances
j'ai décidé de ne pas me touflageller
au contraire si le chemin que j'ai vécu
à travers toutes ces années qui sont qui
je suis aujourd'hui la personne que vous
voyez devant vous aujourd'hui
et j'ai dû utiliser beaucoup de
compassion envers moi-même ce qu'on
appelle aussi de l'auto compassion
mon cher coach
si à chaque que je crois annie a dit que
la capacité
d'avoir de l'autocompassion c'est ce qui
nous permet de créer une sécurité
intérieure et motive
c'est ce qui fait que aujourd'hui je
n'ai plus besoin d'être validé par les
autres pensez ce que vous voulez mais ma
sécurité intérieure elle est
précieuse et j'y tiens beaucoup
que je serai a dit aussi que selon les
études scientifiques l'auto compassion
et le plus puissant moteur au niveau
psychologique et neurologique pour
affronter les difficultés
comment avoir de la compassion envers
soi-même
je vous conseille de vous parler à
vous-même comme si vous parliez à l'être
le plus cher
pour vous
prenez les décisions qui vont vous
soutenir
pensez à votre plus tendre ami quel
conseil lui donneriez vous donnez-le à
vous-même
d'ailleurs en 21 il y a un livre sur la
compassion qui est sorti celui de
Christine nef fears servent comme page
to speak up shreen da paroles
les femmes
sont invitées à utiliser l'auto
compassion pour affronter et
continuer à être elle-même
cette auto compassion elle doit
s'incarner aussi je vous rappelle que je
suis danseuse et que pour moi sentir la
cohérence de mes gestes dans mon corps
c'est vital
je suis très inspirée par plusieurs
autrices afro-féministes un poème de
Twitter ricott parle notamment de la
joie comme acte de résistance et cette
phrase me dit que Audrey Lord le dit
dans son texte l'érotique comme
puissance que quand on sent l'importance
des actions que nous menons dans nos
dans notre corps que nous vivons avec
passion et que nous ressentons dans nos
corps ce que ces actions deviennent pour
nous
nous avons la force de résister et c'est
une manière pour nous de se faire
exister
agir en fonction de nos valeurs être
intègre et ressentir de la joie est une
manière de résister à nos difficultés et
aux oppressions
je reviens avec mon histoire de
leadership narcissique parce que vivre
dans la joie et dans l'allégresse ne
veut pas dire d'être centré sur soi-même
je pense qu'il faut continuellement se
transformer
apprendre sur soi
ne pas laisser nos émotions le 3 mars
nos blessures entacher les relations que
nous avons avec les autres
leadership demande de se remettre en
question de voir l'inconfort comme une
source d'apprentissage
la vulnérabilité comme une possibilité
de connexion avec les autres et avec soi
le leadership demande du courage et de
la responsabilité
c'est accessible à toutes et à tous j'en
suis convaincu et pour moi c'est une
pratique aussi vous savez comme danseuse
j'étais habitude de travailler chaque
jour pour que mon geste devienne fluide
et signifiant pour que à travers mon âme
et mon art je puisse esthétiser un peu
la vie et pour moi le leadership c'est
ça aussi
le lait de chute c'est ce mener soi-même
marcher avec soi-même
et c'est grâce à ce chemin que j'ai
parcouru aujourd'hui que je peux au lieu
de me défendre devant d'autres personnes
mais
gardez toute mon énergie pour agir sur
les causes qui me intéressent
aujourd'hui
vous savez comme femme afro descendante
je ne trouve pas que mon ma présence est
à Nadine
qu'elle est neutre
j'ai été tiraillée pendant plusieurs
jours toute la semaine ça m'a réveillé
toute la nuit je me dis que j'avais un
rôle en fait précis ici que j'aurais dû
parler de l'antirascisme de
détolinisation d'antis oppression
j'ai été trahie en pensant que le temps
que je prenais ici j'aurais dû le
prendre à parler d'autres choses que
parler de mon propre cheminement
pourtant
c'est ce cheminement que je vous ai
partagé aujourd'hui qui m'a donné la
force le courage la détermination pour
après une année en poste à l'Assemblée
canadienne de la danse de mener un
projet de 5 points de millions pour
soutenir les danseuses et les danseurs
au Canada
en développant des manières audacieuses
de rendre cette aide accessible pour les
personnes qui méritent les quitter
donc finalement ce n'est pas si banal
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]